Here, the product was 2x squared minus 1x minus 6. If you got this, you're quite
the pro at multiplying binomials. Now, I know I threw a negative sign at you. So
it's okay if you got stuck. There's also a coefficient of 2 here. So that might
have thrown you off. I'm going to start by listing the factors on each side of
my rectangle. I'll have 2x plus 3 and x minus 2. So I'll have 2x times x, which
is 2x squared. Then I'll have 2x times negative 2, which is negative 4x. Notice
that we're distributing or multiplying the 2x in the first parenthesis to each
term in the second parenthesis. That also happens in our rectangles. Then I'll
do 3 times x, which is 3x. And finally by making a little bit more room, I'll
have 3 times negative 2, which is negative 6, our last area of our rectangle.
And finally, we combine our like terms, the negative 4x and the 3x, to get our
answer.